and so there are three people in the
primarily in computer security it's
myself John Mitchell and David
Mazzarri's we all have very different
takes on computer security i work as i
said on cryptography and kind of other
part of and broadly in many areas of
computer security John focuses on
protocols and David magirus focuses on
secure operating systems so the three of
us kind of complement each other really
well the three of us together we kind of
form the core of the security lab we
cover computer security as a whole
extremely well
among the faculty in computer science
there's also obviously a very strong
interest in security in the sense that
for example the folks doing databases
well there's a security aspect to
database design the folks doing
networking well there's security acts
aspect to networking design the folks
doing architecture well similarly it is
a security aspect to computer
architecture and so really the amazing
thing about doing computer security is
that it plugs into almost everything in
computer science and as a result we get
to interact with everybody so I have
collaborations with almost all over the
department
and just a breath of computer security
Attica probably should probably say a
few words about that so kind of computer
securities is obviously it feeds into
all areas of computer science but it
goes way beyond that so computer
security these days because computers
are so pervasive to our society computer
security essentially effects policy and
you know the government is big into
computer into cyber policy and cyber
security is a big aspect of that it
effects laws that are being made how do
we track cyber criminals that's actually
a fairly complicated problem how do we
know where the attacks are coming from
on the internet nobody knows you're a
dog and the internet attacks can be
coming from anywhere so how do we how do
we adjust our laws to deal with cyber
cyber cyber threats and cyber security
privacy issues you know more and more of
our lives are going online I'm sure you
have a facebook account I mean I should
certainly do and there's a lot of online
data about ourselves available now how
do we deal with private binis privacy
issues there are lots of interesting
policy questions around that and of
course technology questions so how do we
use the data without revealing where it
is there's a lot of commerce that goes
into computer security obviously
commerce wouldn't be possible if we
couldn't transact securely with one
another and so you know we've had
interactions with law enforcement in the
Bay Area when they come to us about
cases where they had questions and we
help them we help answer those questions
for them you know we've had interactions
with lawyers with policy makers with
politicians simply just because we're
working on security it's such a broad
area that I don't know of any other
scientific discipline that's as broad as
security it touches our lives in so many
different points that it's really fun to
work in